[Music]
I want to talk to you today about
something the open-source programming
world can teach democracy but before
that a little preamble let's let's start
here this is Martha pain Martha's a nine
year old Scott who lives in the Council
of argyll and bute a couple months ago
pain started a food blog called never
seconds and she would take her camera
with her everyday to school to document
her school lunches can you spot the
vegetable and as sometimes happens that
sometimes happens this blog acquired
first dozens of readers and then
hundreds of readers and then thousands
of readers as people tuned in to watch
her rate her school lunches including on
my favorite category pieces of hair
found in food this this this was a zero
day that's that's good and then two
weeks ago yesterday she posted this I
posted read goodbye and she said I'm
very sorry to tell you this but my head
teacher pulled me out of class today and
told me I'm not allowed to take pictures
in the lunchroom anymore I really
enjoyed doing this thank you for reading
goodbye you can guess what happened next
but the outrage was so Swift so
voluminous so unanimous that the council
of Argyll and Bute reversed themselves
the same day and said we would we would
never censor a nine-year-old you know
except of course this morning and this
brings up the question what made them
think they could get away with something
like that and the answer is all of human
history prior to now
so what happened when a medium suddenly
puts a lot of new ideas into circulation
now this isn't just a contemporaneous
question this is something we've faced
several times over the last few
centuries when the Telegraph came along
it was clear that it was going to
globalize the news industry what would
this lead to well obviously it would
lead to world peace the television a
medium that allowed us not just to hear
but see literally see what was going on
elsewhere in the world what would this
lead to world peace the telephone you
guessed it world peace
sorry for the spoiler alert but no world
peace not not yet even the printing
press even the printing press was
assumed to be a tool that was going to
enforce Catholic intellectual hegemony
across Europe instead what we got was
Martin Luther's ninety-five theses the
Protestant Reformation and you know the
30 Years War right so what all of these
predictions of World Peace got right is
that when a lot of new ideas suddenly
come into circulation it changes Society
what they got exactly wrong was what
happens next
the more ideas there are in circulation
the more ideas there are for any
individual to disagree with more media
always means more arguing that's what
happens when the media space expands and
yet when we look back on the printing
press in the early years we like what
happened we are a pro printing press
society so how do we square those two
things that it leads to more arguing but
we think it was good and the answer I
think could be found in things like this
this is the cover of Philosophical
Transactions the first scientific
journal ever published in English in the
middle of the 1600s and it was created
by a group of people had been calling
themselves the invisible College a group
of natural philosophers who only later
would call themselves scientists and
they wanted to improve the way natural
philosophers argued with each other and
they needed to do two things for this
they needed openness they needed to
create a norm which said when you do an
experiment you have to publish not just
your claims but how you did the
experiment if you don't tell us how you
did it we won't trust you but the other
thing they needed was speed they had to
quickly synchronize what other natural
philosophers knew otherwise you couldn't
get the right kind of argument going the
printing press was clearly the right
medium for this but the book was the
wrong tool it was too slow and so they
invented the scientific journal as a way
of synchronizing the argument across the
community of natural scientists the
Scientific Revolution wasn't created by
the printing press it was created by
scientists but it couldn't have been
created if they didn't have a printing
press as a tool so what about us
what about our generation and our media
revolution the Internet well predictions
of World Peace Chuck Moore arguing
goldstar on that one I mean YouTube is
just a golf mine
better arguing that's the question so I
study social media which means to a
first approximation I watch people argue
and if I had to pick a group that I
think is our invisible college is our
generations collection of people trying
to take these tools and depress it the
service not for more arguments but for
better arguments I pick the open-source
programmers programming is a three-way
relationship between a programmer some
source code and the computer it's meant
to run on but computers are such
famously inflexible interpreters of
instructions that it's extraordinarily
difficult to write out a set of
instructions that the computer knows how
to execute and that's if one person is
writing it once you get more than one
person writing it it's very easy for any
two programmers to overwrite each
other's work if they're working on the
same file or to send incompatible
instructions that simply causes the
computer to choke and this problem grows
larger the more programmers are involved
to a first approximation the problem of
managing a large software project is the
problem of keeping this social chaos at
bay now for decades there has been a
canonical solution to this problem which
is to use something called a version
control system and a version control
system does what it says on the tin it
provides a canonical copy of the
software on a server somewhere
the only programmers who can change it
are people who've specifically been
given permission to access it and
they're only allowed to access the
subsection of it that they have
permission to change and when people
draw diagrams of version control systems
the diagrams always look something like
this they look like org charts and you
don't have to squint very hard to see
the political ramifications of a system
like this this is feudalism one owner
many workers now that's fine for the
commercial software industry it really
is Microsoft's office it's Adobe's
Photoshop the corporation owns the
software the programmers come and go but
there was one program
who decided that this wasn't the way to
work this is Linus Torvalds Torvalds is
the most famous open-source programmer
created Linux obviously and Torvalds
looked at the way the open-source
movement had been dealing with this
problem open source software the core
promise of the open source license is
that everybody should have access to all
the source code all the time but of
course this creates the very threat of
chaos you have to forestall in order to
get anything working
so amongst open source projects just
held their noses and adopted the futile
management systems but Torvalds said no
I'm not going to do that his his point
of view on this was very clear when you
adopt a tool you also adopt the
management philosophy embedded in that
tool and he wasn't going to adopt
anything that didn't work the way the
Linux community worked and to give you a
sense of how enormous a decision like
this was this is a map of the internal
dependencies within Linux within the
Linux operating system which sub parts
of the program rely on which other sub
parts to get going this is a
tremendously complicated process this is
a tremendously complicated program and
yet for years
Torvalds ran this not with automated
tools but out of his email box people
would literally mail him changes that
they'd agreed on and he would merge them
by hand and then fifteen years after
looking at Linux and figuring out how
the community work he said I think I
know how to write a version control
system for free people they called it
get get is distributed version control
it has two big differences with
traditional version control systems the
first is that it lives up to the
philosophical promise of open source
everybody who works on a project has
access to all of the source code all of
the time and when people draw diagrams
of git workflow they use drawings that
look like this
you don't have to understand what the
circles and boxes and arrows mean to see
that this is a far more complicated way
of working than is supported by ordinary
version control systems but this is also
the thing that brings the chaos back and
this is gets second big innovation this
is a screenshot from github the premier
get hosting service and every time a
programmer users get to make any
important change at all creating a new
file modifying an existing one merging
two files it creates this kind of
signature this long string of numbers
and letters here is a unique identifier
tied to every single change but without
any central coordination every get
system generates this number the same
way which means this is a signature tied
directly and unforgeable to a particular
change this has the following effect a
programmer in Edinburgh and a program in
Entebbe can both get the same a copy of
the same piece of software each of them
can make changes and they can merge them
after the fact even if they didn't know
of each other's existence beforehand
this is cooperation without coordination
this is the big change now I tell you
all of this not to convince you that
it's great that open-source open-source
programmers now have a tool that
supports their philosophical way of
working although I think that is great
I tell you all of this because what I
think it means for the way communities
come together once get allowed for
cooperation without coordination you
start to see communities form that are
enormous ly large and complex right this
is a graph of the Ruby community it's an
open-source programming language and all
of the interconnections between the
people this is now not a software graph
but a people graph all of the
interconnections among the people
working on that project
and this doesn't look like an org chart
this looks like a disorder chart and yet
out of this community but using these
tools they can now create something
together so there are two good reasons
to think that this kind of technique can
be applied to democracies in general and
in particular to the law when you make
the claim in fact that something on the
Internet is going to be good for
democracy you often get this reaction
[Applause]
[Music]
which is are you talking about the thing
with the singing cats like is that the
thing you think is gonna be good for
society to which I have to say here's
the thing with the singing cats that
always happens and I don't just mean
that always happens with the internet I
mean that always happens with media
full-stop it did not take long after the
rise of the commercial printing press
before someone figured out that erotic
novels were a good idea
you don't have to have an economic
incentive to sell books very long before
someone says hey you know what I bet
people would pay for it took people
another hundred and fifty years to even
think of the scientific journal alright
so
so the harnessing by the invisible
college of the printing press to create
the scientific journal was phenomenally
important but didn't happen big and it
didn't happen quick and it didn't happen
fast so if you're gonna look for where
the change is happening you have to look
on the margins so the law is also
dependency related this is a graph of
the US tax code and the dependencies of
one law on other laws for the overall
effect so there's that as a site for
source code management but there's also
the fact that the law is another place
where there are many opinions in
circulation but they need to be resolved
to one canonical copy and when you go on
to github and you look around there are
millions and millions of projects almost
all of which are source code but if you
look around the edges you can see people
experimenting with the political
ramifications of a system like that
someone put up all the WikiLeaks cables
from the State Department along with
software used to interpret them
including my favorite use ever of the
cable Gate cables which is a tool for
detecting naturally occurring Haiku in
State Department pros
[Laughter]
the New York Senate has put up something
called open legislation also hosted on
github again for all of the reasons of
updating and fluidity you can go and
pick your senator and then you can see a
list of bills they have sponsored
someone going by dive geek has put up
the Utah Code the laws of the state of
Utah and they've put it up there not
just to distribute the code but with the
very interesting possibility that this
could be used to further the development
of legislation somebody put up a tool
during the copyright debate last year in
the Senate saying it's strange that
Hollywood has more access to Canadian
legislators then Canadian citizens do
why don't we use github to show them
what a citizen developed bill might look
like and it includes this very evocative
screenshot this is called a DIF this
thing on the right here this shows you
four texts that many people are editing
when a change was made who made it and
what the changes the stuff in red is the
stuff that got deleted the stuff is in
the green is the stuff that got added
programmers take this capability for
granted no democracy anywhere in the
world offers this feature to its
citizens for either legislation or for
budgets even though those are the things
done with our consent and with our money
now I would love to tell you that the
fact that the open-source programmers
have worked out a collaborative method
that is large-scale distributed cheap
and in sync with the ideals of democracy
I would love to tell you that because
those tools are in place the innovation
is inevitable but it's not part of the
problem of course is just a lack of
information somebody put a question up
on Quora saying why is it that lawmakers
don't use distributed version control
this graphically was the answer
and that is indeed part of the problem
but only part right the bigger problem
of course is power the people
experimenting with participation don't
have legislative power and the people
who have legislative power are not
experimenting with participation they
are experimenting with openness there's
no democracy worth the name that doesn't
have a transparency mode but
transparency is openness in only one
direction and being given a dashboard
without a steering wheel has never been
the core promise a democracy makes to
its citizens so consider this the thing
that got Martha Payne's opinions out
into the public was a piece of
technology but the thing that kept them
there was political will it was the
expectation of the citizens that she
would not be censored right that's now
the state we're in with these
collaboration tools we have them we've
seen them they work can we use them can
we apply the techniques that work here
to this TS Eliot once said one of the
most momentous things that can happen to
a culture is that they acquire a new
form of prose I think that's wrong but I
think it's right for argumentation right
a momentous thing that can happen to a
culture is they can acquire a new style
of arguing trial by jury voting
peer-review now this a new form of
arguing has been invented in our
lifetimes in the last decade in fact
it's large it's distributed it's low
cost and it's compatible with the ideals
of democracy the question for us now is
are we going to let the programmers keep
it to themselves or are we going to try
and take it and press it into service
for society at large thank you for
listening
you